impossible de vendre ou d'acheter du
carburant ce matin à cette station du
boulevard général de gaulle les pompes
ne fonctionne plus et pas encore
d'évaluation des dégâts
cette partie de la ville capitale a vécu
des heures sombres entre 14h et passé
minuit le palais de justice
la mairie de fort-de-france il convient
d'effacer le plus rapidement possible
ses traces noirâtres les sépare des
poubelles en feu à l'e3 mais n'ont
malheureusement pas ce que le
les cas ce sont les jeux les poubelles
que tu es brûlé et ça ne sort pas au
sérieux on a essayé avec
bakou michael ça ne soit pas du tout ici
curieux fouilles année les commerçants
s'interrogent partagée entre tristesse
et colère
il faut trouver des solutions si retour
au ça s'arrête un peu mais maintenant
avec la violence je ne sais pas si ça va
arranger les choses
parce que c'est cela seul hic est là ou
là seulement que veut nous aider alors
si personne ne fait ce qu'il faut au
niveau 2
la sagesse est d'être vraiment dans une
relation plus paisible
quel savoie palais je vois on protège
une certaine partie de la population
s'est beaucoup de mouvements toute la
nuit pour le mcg a fait la pub il est à
mon sens militants j'ai vécu dans les
pays bas ce jeudi à des manifestations
mais peut-être une petite bombe à
bayonne
moi mon wales est moins avancée tout cas
de non pas du tout le calme est donc
revenu et il ça devrait aller mieux au
moins jusqu'aux fêtes du roi vaval il
faut l'espérer